In much of Western Europe
and America,
seasonings mean salt and pepper.
They are so strong a pairing that we
even use them to describe people -
think of George Clooney and his
trademark salt and pepper hair.
But where did they come from,
and why do they form
such a ubiquitous pairing?
Salt is essential for life, and it’s
been used since prehistoric times,
either scraped
from saltwater deposits,
harvested from salty lakes,
or mined from underground.
It’s one of the earliest
food industries,
and one of the most important
commodities in the world.
It makes food taste better, but
it's also vital for preservation -
whether of meat or vegetables.
Methods for producing
and controlling it
were developed by all
the classic civilisations,
most notably the Romans,
who left their mark
on modern day language
with their word for salt – sal.
Roman soldiers received their salary
– money to buy salt –
and salads were vegetables
and greens seasoned with salt.
In the medieval period
salt was expensive,
and frequently controlled
by the state.
Huge, ornate vessels for the table
were made out of gold and silver,
dominating dinner tables,
and indicating very clearly
who was of high status.
Sitting below the salt -
i.e. not on the highest table -
well, clearly you weren’t
exactly exalted.
Having salt on the table was
as much for show as practicality,
for dishes were seasoned
in the kitchen,
but adding salt to one’s meat –
with the tip of the knife –
was common practice,
and the uncertain noble
could buy written advice
on exactly how salt etiquette worked
along with the even thornier question
of how to carve.
But how did pepper come to join it?
It was one among a wide range
of spices
available to the medieval cook,
and it was expensive –
in the 1430s one pound of peppercorns
cost as much as a pig.
In the late 15th Century,
the Portuguese took control
of Malabar in east India,
and started cultivating
black pepper on a large scale.
Prices fell,
in line with over supply,
and pepper became
more readily available.
By the 16th Century the phrase
‘peppercorn rent’ was in use,
to mean a nominal sum.
The real boost though,
came with a change in culinary
fashion to favour the French.
They loved black pepper,
and their chefs were busy tidying
and simplifying medieval cuisine,
delineating more firmly
sweet from savoury,
and codifying which
ingredients worked with which.
Salt was obviously savoury.
Pepper tended that way,
and so the fashionable
French-style dishes
of the next century
used both, together,
and with fewer
and fewer other spices.
By the Victorian age,
salt and pepper were coming together
as standard seasonings.
However, other forms
of pepper vied with black,
and cayenne also appeared frequently
in cookery books.
Salt was still on the table -
now in small salt cellars, no longer
just for the privileged few.
In 1911 the Morton Salt Company
of Chicago
patented an easy-flow salt
and salt shakers
could finally take off.
During the 20th Century,
pepper shakers joined them.
Then, as package holidays
introduced Brits
to freshly ground pepper
at the table,
pepper mills replaced the shakers.
Phew.
It’s not a ubiquitous combination
everywhere though –
other cultures might
still have the salt
but replace
the black pepper with chilli.
And let us not forget the pickles,
the sambals,
the vinegars, the fish
sauces and the salsas.
Can I make room on my table
and have them all?